once disciplined lost their way how do I
get back on the discipline train
discipline is not just rigidity like you
talked about being on time I am I always
in five minutes early or like I never do
this that rigidity is also a form of
fragility you have to be resilient and
part of resilience is flexibility being
able to say I can work with this for me
when I think about discipline it's that
my mental status when I talk to myself
is always apologetic and understanding
of things out of my control my core
discipline is I wanted this to be the
case it snowed Mother Nature said go
[ __ ] yourself I said thank you mother
nature and we got in at 3am I'm not
gonna wake up at 6 a.m and work out
because I'm tired and it's okay and I'll
pick it back up tomorrow and that's that
and that that actually requires more
discipline right and so it takes
discipline to be flexible and say I'm
gonna adjust I don't control what
happens but we control how we adjust to
what happens how we respond to what
happens that's actually the the essence
of stoic philosophy right there